tonight we look at the recall effort
against california democratic governor
gavin newsom
the incumbent is getting full support
from the top party leaders
the democratic party in washington but
one expert tells fox news the governor
must unite
the disparate democratic coalitions in
the state to avoid being tossed from
office
here's correspondent mark meredith
there's a lot at stake for californians
today california's embattled democratic
governor won the endorsement of the
state's professional firefighter union
and it's not just the union trying to
rescue gavin newsom
president joe biden and i support him
100 percent
from the white house to capitol hill top
democrats are throwing their support
behind the governor in his recall
election it will be
a time for the governor to prevail
political experts say their backing
and fundraising may be crucial to
keeping the governor's mansion in
democratic hands
he wants to make this recall about
democrats and he's the democrat and he
needs help from democrats
he's in trouble if it's perceived as a
recall about him
the dnc chairman says the party is
united behind newsom but republicans
still see an opening
olympic athlete turned celebrity caitlyn
jenner is generating a lot of
buzz with her campaign while businessman
john cox who lost to newsham in 2018
is spending 5 million dollars to air ads
starting today
we chose pretty over accomplished pretty
boy pretty boy
in his ad cox accuses newsome of
catering to special interests
while keeping california closed our kids
will never again miss an entire year of
school
but recent polling shows 57 percent of
californians approve
of how newsom is handling the state's
k-12 education system
still with the recall election months
away experts warn
newsom's luck can still change newsome's
biggest threat
is probably not a republican but would
actually be a really strong
democrat who is not newsom who runs in
the recall and then anything could
happen
recall fever built up as california kept
lockdowns in place
longer than other states but with
california now reopening and coronavirus
cases dropping
it's unclear how much voters will
embrace pushing newsome out of office
brett mark hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else